let's focus on accusations of racism at
yorkshire cricket county club now uh
county cricket club now club's chairs
resigned and it won't be allowed to hold
any major or international matches the
former player azim murafiq accused the
club of institutional racism and the
story now engulfs the game at both
county and national level and now the
equality and human rights commissions
considering the breaches any breaches of
the law
mohammed patel is a human rights law who
knows and speaks to azeem rafiq
regularly good morning mr patel
and a very good morning to you trevor i
hope you're welcome
i'm well thank you were you surprised
when you heard the allegations made by
azeem rafiq of racist treatment at
yorkshire
not at all
why not
because racism and institutional racism
has been rife
at headingley for quite a quite a long
time now
why do you think that the um
chairman of the club roger hutton um
and
well according to the resign chairman of
the club roger hutton why do you think
the board resisted
reform and took this view that the
allegations were merely banter
all your viewers will know that the
the home of cricket is lords
the heartbeat of the of english cricket
is headingly
and
if the good-natured people like being on
the world's cricket board had not uh
stepped in this week
and if the professor who's an expert in
kindness had not been appointed
uh headingly would have suffered a major
heart attack this week
this is lord patel now who has come in
as a the new chair um that's correct
now you're a proud brad fordian you
follow
the county carefully but you will know
that yorkshire i guess has had a
reputation it was the last county i
think uh to um
get rid of uh the yorkshire only rule to
to have overseas players in
do you think that there's something
about the culture of yorkshire that uh
led to this
i'm glad you have persuaded me to talk
about culture trevor
um historians will always regard
gramsci as the hero of turin
azim rafiq is and will always be
remembered by
being
the hero
for headingley
and i will give you my reasons why
this week
the independent and fearless press
politicians
cricket experts
grassroots
ordinary men and women and children
minority groups disadvantaged groups
all held their hands firmly together
and reset the button
and in one clean swoop the whole culture
of yorkshire has been changed
you think you think it's changed
without a doubt
okay um
rafiq was not the only player who has
alleged uh that
this kind of thing happened to him but
we don't know the names of the other
what why the reason that uh rafiq is the
only one as you
have put it to take this um
uh you've called it heroic stance
uh i will give you my reasons trevor uh
you will know that
um
boys and girls in their teams
will
very quickly choose either to become
professional sports men or women
or they will choose to pursue vocations
or go to university and so on
the reason why
professional sports men and women don't
whistle blow
is because they have to fit in
and this is the reason why it's taken
rafiq a number of years
to give his reasons about the way he was
treated
but there will be many many silent
sports men and women
who will not whistle blow simply for the
reason
that they have to pursue their careers
and their livelihood
do you think um uh do to your knowledge
uh have any of those players
uh take it signed
uh non-dis
non-disclosure agreements or made any
kind of contract not to speak out or is
it simply something that they they feel
they can't do
i have absolutely no doubt that there
will be
a number of sports men and women who
have signed non-disclosure agreements
um in order to maintain the integrity of
the agreements that they have signed
do you think that they're wrong to do
that uh that put yourself in
in the mind of a young player um who may
as i see rafiq has alleged over a decade
have experienced uh belittle belittling
or racial abuse
and even now feels that they can't say
to anybody this is what's happened to me
what what's going on there with that
young person
um trevor you've had a very long and
distinguished career in public life and
i'm going to take you back
to 1990 where
uh the late
minister
geoffrey howe
uh went into parliament and said that
his opening batsman
was sent in with broken bats
um
he was accused
of essentially undermining him
was not only given
a broken back
he left heavily
with a broken mind
and a broken heart
and many sports men and women would have
seen that
and that is another reason why they will
not come forward because the
trauma pain and loss that he has
suffered
uh no sports man or woman would want to
endure what azimuthy can many like him
have enjoyed
you have um
been close to the game you i think have
founded a charity which uh puts on
qriket matches to raise funds for
refugees for children war zones and so
and so forth
is what you've just described
a rare occurrence do you think it is
just something uh true about yorkshire
or do you think it is more widely true
in the sport
uh i would say it is more likely to in
sport trevor
do you talk to young players and um do
they say to you we wish we could speak
out and uh
uh if you tell me all that they tell me
all the time trevor but
but
we have to look forward
in my view
as a proud yorkshire man and like many
other
uh proud gloucestershire man and woman
or any other county
um in yorkshire it's quite specific we
are the greatest cricket club on the
planet
yorkshire people as you know
work hard
we're strong we're resilient
we will put things right and i have
absolutely no doubt
that we shall be the beacon not only for
english cricket but for world cricket
and i hope on this particular occasion
we will
not experience what mr rafiq has
experienced and i think
lots of sports men and women now can be
comforted in the knowledge
that all of us all of us that share the
great values and ideals of the british
way of life
will no longer suffer what mr rafiq has
suffered and i think
the
dramatic events of this week will not
not only transmit
into sport in life but into public life
and the overriding word i would like to
give you and all your viewers
is kindness i think we need to put
kindness back into sport
into civic society
we are the greatest of all nations
uh cricket is absolutely central to us
being
the greatest of all nations and i think
we can all move forward with great
confidence
mohammed patel just last
point here
uh i know you don't speak for zoom uh
rafiq
but what do you think would make him
feel that this has been worthwhile what
action by
lord camus patel who's now the new chair
and yorkshire county cricket club would
satisfy him
he is a professor who's an expert in
kindness
he will give him a big hug
a handshake
apologize
and
in the good old yorkshire tradition
things will be put right mr trevor i
have absolutely no doubt whatsoever
that lord patel and the england and
wills cricket board will put things
right
mohammed patel thank you very much
indeed
thank you so much travis have a
wonderful day
you too